the Johnstone concert ballet are
performing Sleeping Beauty this year and
finish
Chase get in there one two three okay
can you go grab me some water look out
for each other it's gonna be a great
show I'm really excited okay
for this audience it's a fairy tale of
power plants and schemes
with a central character prone to boats
of drowsiness we would like to welcome
you
[Music]
think here of Joe Biden's plans for an
extended run
I feel he's destroying America
what do I think of him I don't know if
he knows he's running again
you know you have transvestites now in
schools dancing
I mean there's a time you go to jail for
that now it's the right thing to do it's
just something wrong with America
I prefer he not to be honest it's not
that I don't like him I just think we
need fresh blood I wouldn't support
Biden overall I find that his
International policies domestic policies
though they you see that there might be
like small changes now currently I think
he's still in like the typical stuff of
in five to ten years you'll see the
lasting impacts of the laws he's putting
in
Johnstone is a steel tone no more
not like it used to be
as Jobs have gone so has much of the
population
there was a time Joe Biden would have
knocked it out the park here
but this is a blue-collar town turned
Republican red
Jared bunk grew up in Johnstown his
cycle shop takes its temperature
economically and socially
we are in a small enough town that we
have the ability to create change here
and work towards change
I think our best chance towards that is
you know is Biden I think it just allows
folks to feel
uh more free to be themselves
in this corner of Pennsylvania the
majority has long since turned us back
on Joe Biden and the Democrat party but
not the last election and at the recent
midterms as a whole the swing state
swung his way
[Applause]
now the curtain goes down here we go
Joe Biden's happy ending hinges on
States like this the curtain will come
down on the incumbent whether it comes
back up is the plot twist yet to play
out
James Matthews Sky News in Johnstown
Pennsylvania
[Music]